hey guys welcome back to reality check
now if the Witcher series has taught me
anything it's that you should never go
into an encounter unprepared no no no
not that what I meant to say is that you
should never go into battle without a
helmet no not that what I really meant
was that you should always draw your
long sword before pillaging the maidens
tomb yep nothing sexy about that I'll
come back once I'm done with the Gryphon
just in case fine happy hunting oh
bloody hell it's not impossible not to
make this game sexy but what I actually
want to focus on is that also important
pre battle preparation of taking potions
read mind-altering drugs before a fight
it's crucial to give our Witcher Geralt
the upper hand when facing off against
gigantic monsters but is this a thing
that people actually do if you want to
excel in combat can drugs really give
you the upper hand
the berserkers were norse warriors who
fought with the nearly uncontrollable
trance-like fury and were famous for the
brutality on the battlefield prior to
combat they would work themselves up
into a frenzy terrifying their enemies
and as legend say making them apparently
impervious to pain they are famously
immortalized in the Lewis chessmen an
ancient chess set discovered in Scotland
and made of walrus ivory the berserker
characters can clearly be seen knowing
on the top of their wooden shields such
is their frenzy for battle nuts so how
did they achieve this bizarre state well
as possible that like Geralt
they relied on consuming drugs before
battle the most likely candidates
include hallucinogenic mushrooms or
excessive amounts of alcohol made from
the local plant bog myrtle it's worth
noting however that it is far from
certain that they actually used drugs
for this at all a number of historians
suggest that this group rage could just
as easily have been achieved through the
power of the mind after all being super
drunk or having crazy vivid
hallucinations might not have been all
that helpful on the battlefield
geralt uses his portions for a wide
variety of active effects everything
from night vision and increased health
to an increased chance of dealing a
critical blow to your enemy very handy
when trying to dispatch a 12 foot tall
where elk or fiend bent on transforming
you into a bloody pile of flesh effects
like these though obviously aren't
possible in real life however there is
one drug induced enhancement that has
been pursued by armies for centuries and
is also at the center of billions of
dollars worth of scientific research
today any ideas well it's actually
something we all grapple with to a
certain extent everyday staying awake
stimulants including tea coffee and
tobacco have been used by historical
armies to keep them from nodding off for
hundreds of years
Prussian soldiers in the 1800s famously
experimented with cocaine to keep them
on their toes and gain advantage over
the enemy fast forward to the Vietnam
War and the US Army's large-scale use of
amphetamines to help give their soldiers
a boost in the harsh jungle combat
according to HowStuffWorks calm on
average every american servicemen in the
vietnam war consumed as many as thirty
to forty and feta mean tablets every
year obviously garel can handle that
dose in one day thanks to his Witcher
metabolism but for a human that degree
of use can result in dangerous side
effects an addiction any drug
administered to our fragile human bodies
you see has a pronounced dose versus
toxicity level the fact this would also
be a problem if we were to adopt
Garrett's approach of brewing drug mixes
out of herbs on the fly sure the
majority of drugs used in medicines and
pharmaceuticals are natural in origin
but the issue with making your own and
the inherent danger of taking horrible
remedies by the way is that you have
very little control over dose you simply
don't know how much active ingredient
you're actually putting in there and
dose makes all the difference between
getting the desired effect or causing
your puny human body serious harm
okay so are there any drugs out there
which could actually help keep a soldier
alert and ready for combat without
causing any nasty side effects in a word
yes
enter modafinil this has been trialed
and actively used on a wide scale by a
whole range of countries around the
world although originally spearheaded by
the US Armed Forces this drug is
designed to help military personnel
function of peak performance for longer
and stave off the effects of sleep
deprivation all the evidence suggests
that it's really quite effective with
researchers actively testing its ability
to keep soldiers functioning for 40 to
60 or even 90 hours without sleep so how
does it work in the brain
well the precise mode of action is still
under investigation but broadly speaking
the drug stimulates the central nervous
system causing increased production of
neurotransmitters and these are
chemicals which act in the brain on
brain cells a number of these
neurotransmitters produced are also
naturally made by the body during the
fight-or-flight response
now the drug will never be able to keep
people awake indefinitely that's not its
goal it's more about compensating for
the lack of cognition when you get all
sleepy and restoring a baseline
performance its most important role on
the battlefield seems is to remove human
error because exhaustion kills fatal
piloting mistakes decision-making errors
and friendly-fire have all resulted from
soldiers attempting to perform their
duties under sleep deprivation so tell
me are you surprised by the amount of
beneficial drug use in the Armed Forces
and what type of narcotic cocktails
would you like to see girl mixed
together before he heads into battle and
the witcher 3 let me know in the
comments last week on reality check i
investigated the history of weaponizing
animals and I also asked you guys what
animal slash weapon combos you'd like to
see in Far Cry 4 now youtube user the
Genki mused still waiting for weaponized
flying squirrels you and me both brother
you and me both okay thanks for watching
as ever folks and i'll see you back here
next week for more reality check